i'm launching my new high-end kahlua
style liqueur snake juice when chris got
back i saw shawn and him celebrating why
would they be happy if he wasn't
supposed to get caught man i love a good
sabotage very angry and i'm really drunk
do you wanna dance with me go get me
another snorkel juice oh that's that's
maybe not the best idea for you forget
it john ralphio yes i'm here dance up on
me yes yes yes
this snake juice is basically rat poison
everybody's wasted you don't even know
one thing i didn't even say what they
can do she asked me the whole thing and
i didn't even do it once i'm like an
elephant okay if i walk into a room it's
like okay he's in there
turn this music down
[Music]
people who buy things are suckers
no no b what if it doesn't work hey we
thought of everything except for an
alibi and an escape route but we'll
figure it out as we go you don't want to
overthink these things kind of freaking
out here go boy i got you this plan is
foolproof and when it's over we can
finally have the lives we deserve
[Music]
i am a safe installer here to install at
a safe so just a point to where the
guacamole money is and i'll uh install
at the safer in the
how you say a place
yeah hi we're being robbed
gee down to us man this hat's a golf
ball and he's got a terrible mustache we
need to get married now
i do
for always and forever
i do
jason going to jail no ma'am
jason's dead
he's suffocating in that safe there are
no air holes
plus he did a bunch of whippets while he
was in there which couldn't have helped
jason i have an idea but it's a little
risky i need you to act as my bodyguard
like my friend kevin costner in that
movie where he was a bodyguard
the bodyguard no problem my cousin once
hired me to do crowd control for his
off-brand sea world well technically it
was just a bunch of kitty pools full of
jellyfish and instead of a killer whale
they killed a whale
up in horsey heaven here's a thing
should i take the cutest puppy or is
that shallow and is it even okay to
separate them are they brother and
sister or or perhaps married dude
they're heaven puppies i'm sure they're
both incredible just choose one you're
right
the black one that was my first impulse
and that is the one i'll take everybody
the harvest festival is tomorrow and i
am so proud of all of you you've worked
so hard you're amazing so i have a
surprise and it is possibly
the best thing to potentially ever
happen to anyone anywhere in the history
of the universe ladies and gentlemen the
world famous lil sebastian what yes oh
my god
oh my god
i never thought i'd get to meet him
truly him well done leslie well done
lil sebastian made his debut at the last
harvest festival in 1987 and he was an
instant phenomenon for the next few
years sebastian was the number one boy's
name in pawnee
and the number three girl's name so what
am i missing what's the deal with this
pony he's not a pony van he's a mini
horse there's a big difference well then
why is he so famous does he do something
what does he do son this horse has an
honorary degree from notre dame we all
need to be very careful okay remember
this little guy's 25 now and he has
cataracts in both eyes he has severe
arthritis jerry's gonna look after him
yes i am we are both on the same
diabetes medication are you my glucotrol
buddy are you
isn't it amazing
yeah i just got to be honest i don't
know what the big deal is
get out i am nourished by your hatred
i've lived
a life that's full
i traveled each and live every day like
it's your last bite me i'ma live forever
[ __ ] ma'am
you know they claim that smoking is bad
for you but is there any medical
evidence to back that up
great point so
the sweetums foundation has really
accomplished a lot recently our
healthcare outreach program has reduced
pink eye in the rural community
by 30 percent
to 70
snooze
you guys ever been fox hunting i have my
own foxes flown in from russia we drug
them pretty heavily so they can't get
very far in fact mostly they just flop
around on the ground makes it easier to
just walk up and bow
stupid foxes
it's deeply erotic that sounds amazing
we should go hunting sometime i'd love
to i could bust out my ralph lauren fall
2010 collection copped it in 2012.
clearance rack wear whatever you want as
long as it's not too
bright or reflective you know i want you
blending in to the surroundings how fast
can you run
i think that guy wants to hunt me
technically i'm homeless
it's open dummy
[Music]
eleanor
typhoon my love
happy anniversary
do you have any regrets not one
not a single one do you have any regrets
are you kidding thousands most recently
this trout how many calories shut up
it's awesome gonna get you started with
some drinks our specialty cocktail
tonight is the fourth of july it's half
an apple pie blended with southern
comfort and coca-cola served in a chevy
hubcap why don't you just go get us
around the beers of course here you go
sorry i
will go physically pick those up
i guess and then walk them back here
with my
feet
miss pinewood recently many of the local
restaurants have changed their small
size option to a whopping 64 ounces
that's correct and it's great for the
consumer more bang for the buck are we
putting bargains on trial here how could
any sane person call that small well if
the customer truly wants a smaller size
there is an option oh do you mean the
little swallow
does anybody buy that some girls buy
them for their doll houses but they're
not very popular i mean for only a
nickel more you get 64 ounces
well uh paunch burger just recently came
out with a new 128 ounce option
most people call it a gallon but they
call it the regular then there is a
horrifying 512 ounce version
that they call
child size how is this a child size soda
well it's roughly the size of a
two-year-old child if the child were
liquefied it's a real bargain at 1.59
i'm sorry miss pinewood but why would
anybody need this much soda it's not my
place to speak for the consumer
but everyone should buy it
you